[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here for those of
you who might not know this I'm
Malaysian and proud to be one as a
Malaysian we love our food we are spoilt
with so many choices and we love to eat
no matter what time it is in the day we
are spoiled with choices and to make
matters worse we have lots of
restaurants which are open 24/7
we are a nation that it's our most of
the time and as a result we are
currently these fattest country in
Southeast Asia almost half of the
Malaysian population aged eighteen and a
berth are either of these or overweight
and you know what I'm scared I'm worried
for my people my nation our kids and the
future generation and the kind of
environment we'll be bringing them into
and I believe that one of the major
causes of this obesity epidemic comes
down to our food what we put into our
body on a daily basis let's face it most
of us are not aware of how bad a food
can be for us because we're used to
eating this way we watch our parents in
this way
hence we feed our kids with unhealthy
stuff as well or perhaps you just don't
care you don't care until something
happens to you high blood pressure high
cholesterol diabetes stroke heart attack
and more I'm not going to tell you to
change your directly or it will ask you
to stop eating out instead let's look at
how we can make healthy food choices
when eating out and still enjoy our
local dishes here's my take on Malaysian
healthy food swap do you know that when
you order a plate of fried rice you're
not just getting one cup but three full
cups of rice that amount has over 1000
calories and over 50 grams of fat that's
half of your daily calorie
recommendation in just one meal sloppy
for economy right instead one cup of
rice served with steamed fish and
stir-fry vegetables has about 400
calories this plate has a balance of
carbs protein and healthy fat to keep
you satisfied not sluggish you'll be
saving over 600 calories and 45 grams of
fat mama lovers
syrota Chennai has about 300 calories
it's basically made from flour and ghee
now that's before dipping it into
courage consuming this on a daily basis
can lead to high cholesterol and
eventually heart attack so that for
Thursday or chapatti instead one piece
of toaster has under 200 calories and it
is a more nutritious option as it is
made from rice split black lentils and
fenugreek seeds we love our NASA Yama
aka coconut rice we have it for
breakfast lunch and even suffer coconut
rice on its own if not a bad choice but
while we choose to serve on the side can
be a killer fried chicken fried egg and
sambal basically no vegetables at all
this one plate has over 800 calories in
67 grams of fat no wonder we are getting
fatter estimation sort that fanatic
rabble instead which is served with a
lot of fresh vegetables herbs and
toasted coconut
this one plate served with grilled
chicken only has about 380 calories it's
high in fiber protein and cups you'll be
saving over 400 calories 58 grams of fat
and your waist line a piece of fried
chicken it's like a sponge it absorbs
all of the oil into the meat this one
piece has about a 390 calories and 21
grams of saturated fat soaked into it
swap it for tandoori chicken instead
you'll be saving 200 calories 16 grams
of fat and you'll be consuming only the
good lean protein for your muscles
typically a Malaysian curry noodle is
prepared with lots of coconut milk and
oil to make it really flavor some hence
it is extremely high in calories and fat
one Bowl has over 600 calories and 37
grams of fat it is not the best option
to consume regularly swap it for clear
broth noodles instead which is way lower
in calories and fat now if you can
request for less noodles and add more
vegetables
do you know that this one tiny piece of
fried spring roll has over 100 calories
let's face it you won't just be
consuming one piece probably three
pieces
now that's 330 calories and 25 grams of
fat just for your afternoon snack stop
that with my favorite series spring roll
instead this large roll only has about
165 calories it is crunchy it's packed
with fresh vegetables and it will keep
you satisfied I love to have this for
breakfast
Pattin Bowl is basically Malaysian salad
consisting of fried fritters instead of
packing the plate with fresh fruits and
vegetables we tend to top it up with a
lot of fried stuff this one plate has
over 500 calories and 23 grams of fat
mainly coming from the sprite fritters
stop it for fruit salad instead which
has about 230 calories and you're
getting all the good nutrients for your
body it is definitely a healthy snack
choice to eat
Brioni rice is cooked with oil or ghee
this one cup has more than 300 calories
and 18 grams of fat
keep it simple and swap it for plain
white rice instead which has about 205
calories per cup and only 0.4 grams of
fat this simple swap will reduce your
fat intake drastically mixed rice can be
a healthier option when eating out so
pick your dishes wisely instead of
choosing fried chicken and sauce loaded
vegetables which can rack your mill up
to 600 calories and 40 grams of fat swap
it for steamed fish or steamed chicken
and lightly stir fried vegetables you're
filling your body with clean protein
fiber and cups you'll be saving more
than 200 calories and 30 grams of fat
and remember to watch your food portion
no adding extra rice one tiny piece of
deep-fried banana fritter has about 120
calories again let's face it we won't be
having just one it will be at least
three servings and that's about 360
calories we basically just turned a
really healthy snack
into unhealthy by deep-frying to swap
and just enjoy banana on its own one
piece of pure nutritious banana only has
about 105 calories and it will provide
you with sustained energy and boost your
workout performance those
innocent-looking carry paths are loaded
with calories and fat one tiny portion
also has about 120 calories again trust
me you will be having at least 3 which
means 360 calories and 18 grams of fat
swap it for steamed sweet potato which
has about 150 calories and only one gram
of fat it's sweet its nutritious and
it's delicious our Malaysian favorite
territory is made with lots of condensed
milk it's extremely sweet and high in
fat just one cup has 180 calories 6
grams of fat and 20 grams of sugar that
amount of sugar is almost the daily
recommendation in just one cup soppy
forte or instead which is only served
with sugar and up for Kerrang money's
less sweet one cup has about 64 calories
and 5 grams of sugar this is similar
with our favorite local coffee again
swap it for black coffee and reduce on
the sugar intake so the next time you
eat out choose grill or steamed over
deep fry and battle dishes when the
audio drinks ask for scoring monies
avoid or reduce on the sauces and
instead of buying many types of Street
snacks just choose one okay
pack your meals with vegetables instead
of asking for more rice ask for more
vegetables and if you can cook more
often instead of eating out all these
food swaps may seem difficult to begin
with but as we started to become more
conscious of our eating habits and
practice making better food choices you
will start to notice of a difference on
your body your energy level and you will
save yourself from unwanted diseases how
you eat will affect your family and
friends just ask yourself are you happy
with your weight right now do you feel
good in your body
feel good after eating or do you want to
see the future generation grew up in an
environment where obesity becomes the
norm we are what we eat we can make a
difference and that starts with each and
every one of us how are you making
better food choices today let me know in
the comments below share your progress
and pictures with me tag me at Atia NASA
official be sure to give this video a
thumb up spread this positive message
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more workout videos and healthy
recipes don't forget to also turn on
your notification button so that you
will get notified every time I upload a
new video on the back